hey everyone it's Mike from overflows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you can join me for today's video
where I'll be talking about sort of the
differences between looking at a
footprint chart right the volume that's
being traded inside the bar as opposed
to just looking at a normal Candlestick
chart now before we jump in you know if
you enjoy learning from these videos
don't forget to subscribe to my channel
and click that notification Bell so you
don't miss a new upload and if you find
today's video helpful you'll make sure
you hit the like button for me and leave
a comment you know sharing your biggest
takeaway or you know some comments in
general about trading I love hearing
your feedback I love hearing about how
other Traders use order flow in their
trading you know trading is a journey
we're all you don't reach a final
destination you're always growing as a
Trader and you know your support you
know your your comments your
subscribing to the channel Etc really
goes a long way in helping me create
more great content just like this so if
you're getting value from my channel
want to see more make sure you subscribe
and let's grow together so let's jump
into today's topic right I I alluded to
it just a little bit earlier about sort
of the difference between trading a
basic Candlestick chart as opposed to
trading a footprint chart which has the
volume that's being traded at each level
and you know a long time ago you know
the early creators of the footprint
chart they say um you see inside the
candle with the footprint and it really
is it's like having an x-ray into how
the candle forms and you know just
recently I got a question from uh D.S
Smith he says I'm no order flow expert
but I think people are focusing on the
numbers and forgetting they are still in
essence looking at a candle right the
body uh and the Wicks are the numbers
remove the color from the candle the
numbers are underneath add color to the
candle you no longer see the numbers all
you see is the body and or the Wicks
moving up or down or remaining still I
try to break it down into its simplest
form yeah I mean really as a Trader you
want to break it down into your simplest
form like I said previously I'm no order
flow expert I don't even use it but when
I saw what was being represented on the
screen my mind's eye came up with
explanation I mentioned above however if
I'm wrong in my explanation someone
please help me understand you know
there's no I don't say there's no right
or wrong in trading you know I remember
being a student in school and I had a
teacher right I remember early in the
year she's like oh there's no right or
wrong answer the only wrong answer is
not answering
and I answered one time and she says
well you're wrong I was like okay he
just you know a couple weeks ago you
said there's no right or wrong answer
but really
um you know when I first started trading
right I
was looking at candles right this was
back in the late 1980s you know Steve
Neeson
um you know had released his big books
on Japanese Candlestick charts you know
like the types he would put on your
coffee table they're so big and thick
like that and you know it wasn't and I I
never really gave much thought into you
know how the candle is forming okay so
let's take a look here right so again
this was today's uh action in the
e-minis right now we had a high of the
day right then the market sold off from
our highs down to new lows okay well why
does the market choose to sell off here
as opposed to here
well for me right and this is why I use
order flows because it allows me to see
inside the candle if I was uh let me
just open up really quick a a simple bar
chart here
uh uh e-minis
and you know it's the same chart so uh
one minute Candlestick chart okay make
sure I got my white uh Candlestick
background
okay so let's just go back here right
this was the high of the day let me get
the crosshairs up
right this was the high of the day we
sold off from this high down to new lows
right then from the lows we rallied back
up not quite hitting the highs but we
had a nice beautiful Rally from
um these lows in the 70s all the way up
above uh double o
and people you know say well what makes
this candle so much better than this
previous red candle or or this other red
candle well to me it's the order flow
right that's why I look at a footprint
chart to give me insights into what's
happening in the market on this red
candle here
yeah I mean you had heavy volume seven
thousand contracts 7
361 but there's nothing really bearish
happening in this bar
okay we're one tick off the high no did
the market sell off well I mean it went
lower from O3 down to you know one and
three quarters five ticks
but this far here in my opinion gave a
much stronger signal of potential
bearish activity that was to come right
we had that Divergence
up here at the highest we had a new high
with negative Delta right over here we
had negative Delta minus 63.
okay here you have a bearish Prominent
Point of control
right up here you don't have a bearish
pound opponent control over here you
have a Stacks selling a balance in the
bar over here you have no selling
imbalances in the bar and even in here
you see a single print one contract
taking place in that bar so while this
is a red candle this is a red candle
two red candles
this is the one the market reacted to
okay even if you're not convinced you
mark it looks like it's going sideways
then you get another red candle with a
bearish Prominent Point of control now I
did a video earlier today on
the importance of the delta
you know at this High giving signals of
a potential sell-off but I didn't even
talk about the point of controls but you
got the bearish prime component control
coming in here in here if you're just
looking at a plain Candlestick chart all
right let me just make this bigger and
get into this area well I don't know
does what how does this one look any
different than this high or even this
High yeah you had a little sell-off here
but this is the one that we powered down
from
um you know the 0506 area down into the
70s
but it was the signs by looking inside
of the bar at the actual order flow okay
now let's take a look here all right
because we made these lows down here
why did the market rally off this low
and not this low
or this low right here's your bullish
engulfing pattern right here right
here's your Hammer Candlestick pattern
right the bullish One Market you know
technically the market went up a little
bit here why did the market rally off
this bullish hammer
okay is that a hammer I get confused on
all these Candlestick names
um you know the long Wick down you know
here you got a bunch of Wicks right I
know people have trade Wicks right
saying oh the market is rejecting these
areas well okay came back down and
traded there came back down blew through
that area but here
the nice rally off of why
well that's why looking at the order
flow is going to give you my estimation
my view
um you know much better information to
trade off of Okay so
look at this right we're
where was all these Wicks here right all
these Wicks coming in here this whole
area big Wicks right this is all just
Wicks from this 85 area down to 83 and a
quarter it's all wicks
nothing bullish coming in here right
people say well you got these Wicks you
know that indicates price rejection well
yeah technically the market went up two
points if that even but it's no real
sign in the order flow of price
rejection if anything you're seeing
still some you know selling Wayne on the
market
okay so you've still got selling Wayne
on the market chances are probably going
to go lower
right came down here another big wick
down the market go up yeah a little bit
Mark another big wick down Market go up
point and a half Market starts powering
down got very bearish point of controls
get down into down into here new lows
right big green candle up and golfing
pattern well Market didn't go anywhere
positive Delta of 28 here positive Delta
of 283 nice green candle I got a couple
buying imbalances you know maybe Market
could start to Rally well didn't you
know you have a bullish slingshot point
of control here and it came back with
the bearish uh Prominent Point of
control here then look at this low at 10
55. what do you have coming in here
got a few things right you got well
first of all you got three pointed
controls lined up one two three right so
you got that uh
a bit of balance forming down here at
the low
then as you start moving away from the
low
what do you got you got this bullish
point of control you got one two three
mind imbalances right
over here earlier right you did have the
Divergence you don't have a bullish
point of control you still got one two
three bind imbalances okay so I know a
bullish point of control is a sign of
support okay so I know I got support
coming into this market so not only do I
have support coming into this Market but
I have aggressive buying coming in
okay yeah I've got positive Delta 150.
it's positive it's not like
overwhelmingly positive
um then I get another bar red candle
down with positive Delta which is
actually bullish I've explained that in
other videos another bullish Prominent
Point of control here so I got one two
point of controls that are bullish right
but at this point right if you're just
looking at the market like this
right it looks like we're just going
sideways which you know even though
we're making these new lows it's
basically going sideways between you
know 76 and 73 more or less I love that
you have these three pointed controls
um forming at the same price level down
here because that indicates to me that
there is support coming in right at that
level of 73. so if I know that there's
support at 73
right I just draw my line there this is
my support area okay are we staying
above it yes do I see bullish order flow
coming in yes bullish power point of
control in here right another
um slingshot point of control but I do
have a bearish
Prominent Point of control coming in
right here
comes off a little bit this is my
support area at 73 bullish power point
of control zero print okay
at this point I know that I've come in
I've tested the support area and again
why is to me 73 support because it's
formed by volume in the market
right it's formed by these three bars
volume then I see the bullish order flow
come in and now I could be
looking that yeah this Market can start
to rally and again if I'm wrong
I'll know pretty quick right I'll know
if we break 73
I'm completely wrong
and we don't right we just keep going up
thin print zero thin print zero bullish
pound important control you got more
imbalances here you got one two three
here you got one two three buying
imbalances
okay and the market proceeded to Rally
up so in my opinion you know yeah it's
fine looking at Candlestick charts right
I mean
that's how I started right I started
charting candlesticks by hand back in
the late 80s you know when I was still
in college and
um you know we don't have the Computing
software you know the charting software
and back then you know it's like
metastock was the main thing that retail
Traders had in tradestation but if you
remember back in the 80s tradestation
was like
two thousand dollars or three thousand
dollars metastock was just uh 180 bucks
or something like that not even 200 but
um you know and even then with metastock
it was just basically end of day data
um getting real-time data was very
expensive back in the 80s and early 90s
so
you know it's nice to look at
candlesticks I mean that's how I started
I still look at candlesticks that's why
that was one of my main things with my
softwares you know I told my programming
I still want to look at the candlesticks
right because it's still important to me
price action is still a part of my
Trading
right but I use order flow
to boost it
right because I I want to know what I'm
seeing and you know and just again you
know I know the low of the day here is
72 and a quarter and I see what's coming
down into it then I see strong Deltas
here and here Delta volume 30 25 right
we're closing near our Max Delta of 455
we close at 452. uh Max Delta of 1042 we
close out one thousand and three so I
know there's strong aggressive buying
that I'm not going to see that on a
normal Candlestick chart right I can see
yeah I could see a big green candle
which indicates to me that yeah there's
obviously buying taking place I just
don't know the intensity of it but by
looking at the order flow it gives me
a clear reading of what that intensity
is all right so
that's going to wrap up this video on
you know sort of the differences between
looking at a plain Candlestick and
looking at an order flow volume
footprint so you know I hope you found
this useful uh for your understanding of
order flow and let me know you know what
you'd like me to discuss on on another
video in the future uh by leaving some
comments below so
just make sure you subscribe to the
channel if you've enjoyed this video so
you don't miss you know any of my
upcoming videos I've got another one
planned based off of another user
comment and you know we're you know the
whole point of doing this is is to
improve your trading so thanks guys I'll
see you on the next video bye-bye